it's really tough for girls at the
moment there is this ever dwindling pool
of guys that are eligible for you you
have more opportunities than ever before
society says that you shouldn't become a
mother you maybe want to have a career
but also like the idea to have a family
but if you have a family treated like a
second-class citizen that's been conned
by the patriarchy into becoming a
domestic prostitute if I was a woman I
really wouldn't know what to do no me
neither the one difference is that men
are still having the finger pointed at
them and being told that they're The
Architects of their own misery and also
the architects of everybody else's as
well if there's ever a problem with any
group usually we would say okay what's
going on how can we try and change the
world or Society so that we can help
this group flourish there's not enough
women going to University in 1970 so we
introduced Title IX now the gender split
between men and women is 15 instead of
13 when it was in 1970 but in the other
direction so there are fewer men going
to University than there were fewer
women going to University when that
title was introduced and now it's like
why are men falling behind can't they
pull themselves up by their bootstraps